Hey so glad you could make it come on in
so this is my set up tour it's finally
happening as you see right away there's
just dope as whiteboard where I keep all
my most important information being a
youtuber I have to be organized and make
sure I write down what I have to do
wait don't film this
this is what I pray to Odin three times
a day please give me more subs Odin
that's a trash can
oh it looks like we got a gift
edgert what were you doing there you're
ready for more let's keep the tour going
Michael how's the diamond play button
doing looks screwed what do you think
mrs. spot I want that [ __ ] polished and
clean
if you missed a spot you're out Michael
if the Romanian follow me don't be shy
hell yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
these panels look like a toddler drew
them but they were done by me I think it
looks pretty cool it gives that room a
bit more personality instead of a normal
wall I don't know I like it
alright [ __ ] you oh yeah baby this is
how real men record I'm their goddamn
feet can do squatting if I want how do
you think I maintain this great ass
it feels like I'm wearing nothing at all
nothing at all nah got my microphone on
a shock mount it's not it's not the best
one but you don't need a great
microphone at least if you're not
purified as long as you can yell in it
that's all you need baby
the next alaric so he goes to this goes
to this little baby right here I
honestly don't know how it works
got my sweet ass glorious mouth pain I
managed to find the tiniest keyboard out
there oh wow ah now I can truly relax Oh
what should I play today
you got my my beauty light
the ring light all the buter Gauri's use
it to look good I don't need it to look
good but a camera it's a Canon with a
shotgun mic on top of it so in case I
[ __ ] up and I didn't record my [ __ ]
this one is a lifesaver this one is a
live scene look at the setup though it
looks [ __ ] dope
it's [ __ ] on camera tell me right now
you wish you had this setup baby alright
my headphones they're Wireless so in
case I'm making videos I can move around
I can do [ __ ] I can kick the walls if I
want to don't want to though I can move
over here I can move over here I can
disappear you wouldn't even know about
it
now I know what you're thinking this all
looks very pretty boots
but what about how does it look behind
the scenes oh boy I got a lot to show
follow me are you ready for this I don't
think you're ready for this
oh oh that organization oh oh come over
here brain
come over here look at this they go out
I got all kinds of [ __ ] oh my god and
it's so neat and tidy [ __ ] that's why
you thought I was a dirty hoe
I am the cleanest [ __ ] this guy
is clean as a [ __ ] Brad what are
you doing come on you got to keep up
it's time to check what's inside I know
you're curious like a little kid on
Christmas what's inside the package Papa
put more pine cones this year Papa
paired okay so this is actually a server
cabinet I have so many consoles and
computers cable is [ __ ] everywhere
the let's get right into that [ __ ] I'm
gonna link all my specs in the
description because I know a lot of
people care and then a lot of people
have no idea what I'm talking about
but all you need to know is this is a
bomb-ass computer and it is fast Xbox
above GameCube I got em all alright I
could fit a bunch I could fit as many
consoles in there as I like and I lock
it at night so no one touches my [ __ ]
all the cables tonight me goes into one
pop goes right in there
it looks nice as [ __ ] that's right
that's right that's right now it was
kind of a problem having a standing desk
with the cable being fixed but I think
and did a pretty good job
look is that a clock that is a clock
that is a huge-ass clock so I can know
the [ __ ] time of how long I've been
recording and [ __ ] what is the time
today it I'm aim let's see here it's 15
and son hey Bret have you seen this [ __ ]
the LEDs
I can change them what call you what's
your favorite color [ __ ] fly on that
[ __ ] on you ever have a girl over you
say that line she be dripping whoa it's
Christmas babe I got the cinnamon candle
I got the Christmas lights father
christmas comes early and prop up his
house michael keep polishing what did I
tell you keep polishing the diamond play
button if I see one more little smudge
on it I'm going to call YouTube and have
you responsible
are you using the bleach now get out cuz
I need to take a nap
you forgot to do the outro I when I
started making videos I was literally on
this tiny [ __ ] table I couldn't even
fit my keyboard on it so tuned I made it
guys I [ __ ] made it
I got my dream setup now honestly since
we got kicked out I really wanted to
make this setup the way I really really
wanted and it was really fun to work on
it and I'm just very happy with it so I
hope you bros enjoyed watching if you
did leave a like and as always stay
awesome res are you playing poker go to
so you do it you catch it again to drive
here behind you dude we see the same
polka scene yeah no I put the zeros we
found the all the same Pokemon this is
so cool this is it his real or something
it's always like the Pokemon is there
now we just got hit by a car and we're
gonna go to Z front to do some fishing
maybe I'll find some magic hums magic
curse